oh gosh Wayne way die virgin yo what is
up guys and today I'm going to be doing
a modern view of blood magic hence my
candy sword chillies in a candy store
today is a sacrificial knife yeah
sacrifice you but yeah I'm prestige you
don't know me and I'm doing a mod review
on a minecraft 1.6 point2 mile Oakland
magic now there's a lot in as far as you
can see about a many item a crafting
recipes so let's hop brain to it this is
a mod where you can have lots of like
like lund arcane dark magic in New
spooky spooky so the kind of stuff
heroine will be into so your first thing
you need for everything is your blood
alter that you see here you see the
three tiers now craft it you need for
stone a furnace to gold and a document
you'll be at tier 1 here we have tier 2
here and then we have tier 3 which is
the ultra 3 by 3 square of runes it
doesn't have to be this room just n-type
arun and another layer of rooms going
around it Plus these pillars know every
all the rooms and stuff and pillars are
required a lava and temple pyramid is
not required this is for show so this is
the best type of thing and it's not too
hard to make sense if you can make a
room you can make these you can do with
Nolan's so it's they're doing that now
the first thing is you okay so you need
the sacrificial knife which is something
that's going to be charging everything
is based off LP like points or life
essence or soul network or whatever so
right here we see it's an iron it's a
gold and some glass the sacrificial
knife when you are using your
sacrificial knife if you're near your
thingy I click I right click it takes
some my heart that's 200 LP and charges
this thing
LP now if we go back to game mode 1 and
I go to a sigil yes I got so I'm going
to be using this the entire thing just
this the divination sigil will show me
how much LP is and stuff so that has
10,000 that is full max LP my network
has 5000 since I missed that I've only
made the one thing that lets me to up up
to 5,000 when i'll show you that so you
need diamond emerald a block of gold
actually you can do it one at a time
really did aminute so if you throw your
diamond in there are you going to get in
charge you can get some red particles
once the red particles were off you're
going to right click it again and you're
going to take out your blood orb now if
we have the weak weak blood or two
swords wild life essence just Kim let's
hear it make everything work well if I
click right it'll attach it to me and it
see corona mad Luigi and yeah so now
that bumps my overall LP network 5000 as
you can see because overall ipad has
them now if we give it a little more I
don't that give it a little more blood
that's up to 10,000 agree good and we
throw an emerald in there alright we're
cooking with Betty Crocker now for your
first item Union emerald gonna throw it
into the blood altar and going to stir
it up with some elke or life essence4u
news and once you get do you get these
glowing red particles you know it's
working and once you get these little
gray particles emitting or no particles
you can take it out and while I you have
your apprentice spluttered I hit it I
should of upped it to ya 5200 up I can
do this so the more I do it the higher
goes obviously if I was in normal mode
it would take a lot more energy because
it would take hearts off of me and it's
a sword in there what if the altar
current essence runs out then it's going
to start draining from your current
essence and if your current instance
network is at zero which can drain from
your heart and
so we have now we have our dagger of
sacrifice this will let me hit an animal
and then if it's near the altar you see
the altar right now is that 7385 we
place a cow down I kill it instantly
dies and it feels that now the coward I
think does like 250 this fight it oh I'm
peaceful the spider I think we'll do
like a more clothes like 500 or yeah
somewhere neither likes of shape that's
going to be another 250 and then the
villager is just something like 2,000 or
something it's really intense so it has
to be near altar so that's what I'm not
going to be a viable plan so we're going
to throw our block of gold in there come
on take the altar Jos all turtles altar
at all you can get an ulcer just get you
far away cygnet dad oh yeah all right um
yeah the gold block takes like 40
thousand so we're gonna once it gets
down to zero oh also if it runs out of
essence actually no it doesn't take from
yours it runs out of essence then it's
like this will slow all great particles
it does thats that means it's slowing
down and it loses progress on the i lose
progress on oh no well else okay my bad
our blood altar okay just to save you
guys the time of wake up now that is a
cow that is a cow just save you guys a
time of waiting you do that you get the
magician's of blood or which can make
your overall essence go up to like
150,000 so definitely worth it but that
is definitely something that if you can
make your going to want to and you just
stand with so many times so it's get
into build it crackin recipes so over
here we have the runes stone covering a
week apprentice or and then you get
yourselves to
a normal room box you got a normal room
block stone and redstone you get the you
get the efficiency room that makes
everything go faster use less if you put
in blood moon to blood room to stones in
these X shape and sugar get the speed
room that makes things go faster
efficiency call it makes cost less over
here gives you more expensive rooms
stone apprentice or and gold you get
yourselves or butter margarine whatever
you guys want me to call it you get that
rune I actually don't an angel e so you
get the rune of sacrifice which helps it
go faster like better like when you kill
an animal near it gets more and over
here the room self-sacrifice same
crafting recipe but you do glow stone
powder so those are all the rooms for
upgrading the alterant abetted stuffs
and over here we have the slates which
is going to be used in the residuals so
we have one iron surrounded by gold and
some stone and we get the blanks sigil
blank slate and you get some iron
covering a blank slate redstone and some
glow stone and then you get your
advanced slate or harden so what I wrote
is over here is the sigils which I use
in creation with the slates first off we
got our divination sigil which is very
good it shows me what the heck did I do
no source current essence I say always
keep this on you can do this mod it's
blank slate week apprentice or covering
glass boom here we have a water sigil
infinite source block if it's like
heaven bucket of water with you forever
forever bro and over here we have the
counterpart to the border which is the
lava digital which is basically like
infinite lava bucket pound pound pound
it is with six lava buckets blinks is a
lot of crystal and meg whitman hellova
crystal over here we have a diamond
the blocks of obsidian lava buckets to a
glass and a week apprentice orb you get
that over here we are going into the
more advanced sigils a party in slate
which is empty buckets on the sides
events a in the middle strings and that
orbit get the boys is you'll save the
lava sigil boom and the voices yeah
voices gets a rid of sore spot we have a
same thing except replace the string
with a ghast here and replace the
buckets with feathers and get the air
sigil and let me tell you this is
probably the best digital ever since it
makes you like do this each one of these
calls tell p but like and you still get
fall damage but i go to game mode 0 it's
like hard to kill yourself of this you
can see because it's in my using my LP
cuz my he's like full I do not take any
damage myself we still hiding go whoa
coo coo coo coo cool see no damage to
myself let's see how much from Sophia do
that like took like 2000 dope nope nope
fire go away go away fire fire bad fire
their way from of my beautiful I'd max
our game mode no one hop on over we got
our mining sigil which is advanced
digital events late a bunch of tools and
that it gives you hey slow down into
some stone open up that is bad idea goes
why Kevin oh hello ok but so as long as
we have this activate it gives me a
passive in fact effect of haste game
mode 0 and it'll use LP but it'll make
me go fast as you see it gives me
constant haste as long as it's activated
and I'm going faster than normal sap
that's cool now here we have the
elemental
digital which is all of your elemental
sigils that you have had previously air
water fire advanced late in the middle
obsidia on the corners and a magician
like advanced magicians orb you get that
one sigil of elemental affinity
basically it makes you impervious to all
like damage like say I go to it protects
me from fall damage war drowning and
jump I already said jumping nine lava so
sad you at some lava I go to a mode 0
and I have that activated fire
resistance I am impervious to fire I can
feel the flames burning it feels so good
all right now lastly we have our like
portal blocks or room blocks of ink
master that's a ritual stone sorry we
have our master we have our virtual
stones now a toucan Emperor virtual
stone you take your week apprentice or
stone obsidian you get that I really
don't know what it is used for seed for
weaker ones I'm not really sure I think
you can place it under a block of like
any source and it gets rid of it like a
lot of our water thanks so now over here
we're basically every single thing we do
we're going to need a master ritual
stone and we're going to need playing
ritual stones so if we get master patrol
stone you get a advantage itions or some
vegetable stones around it and some
obsidian you get math virtual stone and
over here this actually gives you
forward so it's a good deal yet obsidian
all current and apprentice magicians or
baguette for virtual stones which are
used indication of this or in the actual
things now each ritual stone to be used
to I need to be painted with like
elements all of these things elemental
inscription now to get these you have to
throw certain items into the altar like
gas here string something else and
something else I don't know I'd say
looking a week you for that look in the
wiki for all these are looking just
searched up and find the wiki about it
the Creator posted thing and
explain like all the actual LPS now if
you paint each one these are the
different things and we go over here we
can see them all laid out how we do it
now this one is blue distillers blue
this colors red the brown clothes
actually green and he Blue's Clues the
blue one there so yeah I think you need
an activation crystal for all of these
so we're going to get a week activation
crystal and I'm going to plop on there
and or what up this one is an infinite
water supply I say or get multiple
buckets 16 buckets and I go to game mode
0 this can be used for a mod with
pumping or a mod with any sort of like
yet pumps or stuff if you want to get a
lot of lag you just this its infinite
sealed in water buckets and we move on
and we have 18 675 we hit that hit that
hit that hit that hit hit that hit that
come on oh hello underman her so this is
not working alright guys I found order
was it was actually I did not have
enough I didn't have enough LP my thing
isn't so requiring 20,000 to start yet
really drained me down and there we have
infinite lava source so if I place
bucket of water well that kind of ruined
it didn't it didn't it yeah so it'll
it'll keep creating at you in a few mess
with it so over here okay where need
more OMG so let's go
don't touch me I should be enough and
voila that this is the one that gross
stuff so if you have like what the heck
it's got like a tree above it it'll
increase the growing speed yeah he's
like let's meet up dirt over it over
here okay so this basically keeps
animals away just run away and fail and
fail ha yeah you just click it in and
keep the animals away where they didn't
cause much basically each second uses
stuff to keep an overlay all right let's
get to get mad all the way we keep them
a stupid cows are well guys I think I've
covered everything in this mod if you
have enjoyed any part of this video make
sure you leave a little like rate
comment or subscribe and I hope to see
you all next time in another macho case
or anything else in my videos
you